what's up alex how can i help i'm uh 31
uh in the process i have a fiance we're
in the process
of planning our wedding and doing the
baby steps just to provide a little
context we're on baby step two just
running through it as quick as we can
getting all your debt paid off huh yeah
i picked up a side gig
you know doing good as far as that
concern as far as that's concerned but
where it gets a little messy is
my family is going through a bit of a
financial hard time
um which is not normal um it's just
they're in a bit of a transition period
and i know from listening to the show
the dave ramsey showed that like the
right thing to do is take care of me so
that i'm in a position to take care of
that
take care of them or you know just
prioritize my own family and
i understand that but it doesn't feel
good yeah it doesn't feel good to be
making you know big payments towards my
dad and
essentially building my future but then
my parents even though this situation
you know
maybe temporary are are not in the same
position
that that doesn't emotionally that's
hard to
carry uh that cinder block's hard to
carry to you your analogy
look at that look at you alex so hey i
listen a lot
i appreciate that so are you feeling
this
from them or is this just something
you're carrying around
no no no it's just are they hitting you
up for money and saying man it must be
nice and
no no not at all okay yeah not at all uh
they i mean
they would want nothing more than you
know me to be able to progress
the way that i have and there no there's
no ask from them at all this is just an
internal thing
have you ever taken your dad out
and just or your mom out and just said
hey tell me what's going on things
looks like things are hard um talk me
through it we're both grown-ups i'm
about to get married like what's going
on
could you all have that conversation
yeah so we we
have a great um we have a great rapport
with my parents and i so i know
what's going on basically wow okay um
you know basically it's just my dad is
in a bit of a career transition
uh you know he's works in automotive
industry things have changed they would
rather
hire you know five people and pay them a
low salary versus higher one and pay
them a high salary so there's a
there's a bit of a transition there and
uh he's working through it and i think
it'll be
fine you know they're not in dire
straits or anything it's just
it doesn't it doesn't feel good it
doesn't feel good to
make a big student loan payment um when
i know that they're
you know just not able to live the way
that they typically live
you know what i mean yeah so how can i
help you man
i just i guess um i
i come from a place where you always
take care of your family and now that
i'm engaged you know even though we're
not married
you know i was always taught that you
know once you are engaged
you take care of your family so i
understand that what i'm doing is taking
care of my family but
not to sound like a broken record i just
i want to know
how to feel better you know what i mean
how do you balance that you know
yeah how do you how do you balance
taking care of your own family and
while knowing that the other side of the
family is not
on the same page you know yeah so
um how honest do you want me to be with
you
100 are you for real
yeah all right um here's the honest
truth
nothing
when you have when you love somebody
and they're hurting you're going to hurt
too
when you put up boundaries that are
going to keep you well
and whole protect your family and not
only protect that sounds so
draconian and dramatic to
um to keep you
healthy to keep you alive to keep you
whole
so that you can be in service to other
people when you do that
it hurts because people they they want
to hit their head up against that
boundary or you can look over your
your boundary and see that they're
struggling and
you recognize in your heart you're not
in a shape you're not in any sort of
shape to go there and help them
right and so you're just kind of stuck
and you can be a presence you can be
positive you can
connect but you can't solve their
problem and there's a feeling of
powerlessness there
that just hurts right and there's
something about i wish i had a
less lame word there's something about
growing up you just recognize that
sometimes in life things just suck they
just hurt man
and there's no magic solution other than
to sit next to folks and say i
i i hate this for you and
man i've had taken calls you've probably
heard them where
parents are calling their kids begging
for money and they're trying to keep up
a lifestyle they're trying to keep up
the situation right and
that's even harder but it's easier right
because i can get i can get angry at
those parents for preying on their
children
this isn't that way it just sounds like
you've got a big huge heart you have a
great close family
and you're just watching them kind of
flounder around a little bit and it
hurts
yeah i've kind of learned this year that
sometimes making
the best decision uh hurts the most you
know and i think
maybe this is one of these one of these
scenarios yeah so
here's the here's the typical and i'm
gonna i'm gonna over
stereotype this i'm gonna over
generalize it and over gender it okay
what a lot of guys do in your situation
is they start flexing
and they withdraw and they just seek out
numbing behaviors whether that's i'm
gonna work some more hours i'm gonna get
another side gig
i'm gonna learn the drums i'm gonna
have two extra drinks i'm gonna fill in
the blank
right and what i would challenge you
with as you're entering into
a lifelong commitment as you're entering
off the edge of the you know off the
high dive here
and starting your new marriage i want
you to develop an ability to be
vulnerable with your
with your fiance with your future wife
be vulnerable with your buddies
that you have here in town that you may
still have from college that you have at
work
that are safe and people that you trust
but man start practicing hey this is
hard i'm
really struggling with my parents
situation and i'm spending all this
money
you can even sit down your fiance if you
haven't already i'm sure you have but
say
i just i know this is going to be weird
but i just need to be vulnerable and say
i'm really struggling my my parents are
struggling it just makes me sad
and i'm sorry about that and hopefully
she is of the caliber a person that's
going to say
i hate that for you and it's going to
give you a hug you're going to watch a
show together and
and do whatever you know i mean go for a
walk whatever the thing is going to be
but
i don't want you to experience this pain
and immediately run from it
okay it can be i appreciate that
all right is that what you're doing yeah
i mean i probably worked 85 hours last
week just getting stay busy
just running yeah yeah working 85 hours
in your baby step two and you're trying
to for those of you don't know what that
is that's
uh man it sounds like alex and his
fiancee are trying to pay off everything
they own be debt-free by the time they
get married
um man sometimes you work out 85 hours
right before you get married you're
trying to grind it out and
you know get your debt paid off that
happens but you and i both know
when we double down to work more right
i'm gonna i actually sent a text message
to
the guy that runs everything for me here
and said i'm having a rough couple of
weeks i'm going to bury myself in work
over the next two months
i sit that and i do this for a living
man so this is the pot talking to the
kettle here
but there's something to be said for um
talking to fiance and saying hey i just
need you to know i'm struggling it's not
you
i'm excited about our wedding i'm
excited i love my family i just hate to
see them hurt and i don't really have a
tool set for that and the tool set is
just to sit there
and um let your feelings be heard and
then you got to get up and go back to
work right but
it's it's both and not either or is she
somebody you can you can talk to about
it
oh yeah for sure so um we we really
like emphasize communication so i've had
a conversation with her and this is her
response you know the conversation went
a lot like what you said and she
said to me she said this is you know
what you're feeling right now is
basically why you need to complete the
baby steps
you know because if you complete the
baby steps you know the way that dave
says
when they really do need something we
can be there for them when we have the
baby step three and the four and
you know all those things we can be
there for them when they really need
something that's that's why we need to
do it
and rather you are you are marrying
really well
man good for you punching outside my
weight clutch
way out kicked your coverage on this one
yes that's all that's just a wise person
right
if we will hurt now and do hard things
right now it's going to give us freedom
that no one in our family
even understands later on right and that
doesn't make it easy
maybe you do have the conversation so
let's say your dad doesn't get a job in
the next 24 months
and things get messy right go ahead and
have that conversation now what would
this look like for us
or are our parents ever going to move in
with us that's a good conversation to
have now
right and they can be hypothetical and
they can be funny and they can be
whoa they can live in a tent in the
backyard i mean however you all have
conversations like that but
i'd recommend this using this
opportunity and if you tell your fiance
hey i want to practice being open about
these hard things
use that language with her it will give
you
it will give her some grace with you
when you say things wrong you stumble
over it will give you permission to kind
of lean into it a little bit
and hey listen spouses
if somebody if some partner comes to you
and says
hey i want to be vulnerable here don't
weaponize that
don't be ugly about it don't make fun of
don't give advice
just sit and be still even if it's not
your picture of masculinity even if it's
not your picture of
why don't you just solve and get over
with don't do that man
i hear a lot guys who are married will
say i finally
was honest i sat down and told my wife
i'm struggling
and she looked at me like i was the
biggest wimp she'd ever seen
it was embarrassing and then she
go off and tell her girlfriends my
husband's a whiner but don't do that
don't do that man if somebody gets the
courage to be honest and
vulnerable please honor that that
that moment right that pause in their
when they set their armor down right
honor that alex you're in the right
place man there's nothing that's going
to make this go away
and um i'm grateful for you for having a
good heart
good for you man sit with it be honest
and if you can take your dad out for
coffee and just say hey man how are
things
do that it's going to build your bond
with him it's going to give you some
news
community communication skills between
um
you and him together it's going to be
good so thank you so much for that call